hi there you may have seen this brief
video before but I'm publishing it again
because it has been much
improved if you recall in my first
welcome video I pointed out that I
really don't know but we'll eventually
learn all the technical aspects of
running a YouTube channel not long
thereafter the owner of the YouTube
channel dose of Truth reached out to me
and a long story short has been of great
help among other things he took the
liberty to mightily improve the video
you are about to watch specifically by
adding text and video overlays I think
that's what they're called thanks again
to dose of truth and you let me know
what you think in the comments do you
want to see more videos like this a duck
walks like a duck and quacks like a duck
it's probably a duck this is wise
Council whenever the media and experts
insist that you not believe Your Lying
Eyes take the ongoing issue where men
who perfectly fit the profile of radical
Muslims engage in the usual acts of
Islamic terrorist is M only for the
authorities to turn around and tell us
not to be Hasty and jump to
conclusions remember for example the
African son of migrants who three little
girls age 6 seven and N in Southport
England just last summer although the
random people especially children has
long been a chief Hallmark of Islamic
terrorism openly sponsored by ISIS the
Islamic State British media and
politicians were quick to shame anyone
who dared suggest the murderer was a
Muslim as an islamophobe instead they
insisted that he was a Christian whose
family was heavily involved with the
local church according to one report a
few months later it turned out that this
supposed Christian was Reading jihadist
literature including a document called
military studies in the Jihad against
tyrants Al in Arabic and had even
produced the biological toxin ryen to
kill even more infidels then there was a
Syrian Asylum Seeker in France who a
year earlier also so in the summer of
2023 went on a spree in a playground
repeatedly toddler and knifing a total
of four children age three again
although this was a very typical
jihadist Behavior the media told us not
so fast he was obviously a Christian
since his name was very Christian
sounding Abdul massiah servant of Christ
and rather than issue the usual Muslim
war cry that accompanies these types of
attacks Allah abbar he had reportedly
cried out in the name of Jesus Christ
while holding his cross necklace before
initiating in his Rampage a day or two
later though Christian migrants from
Syria stepped forward saying they
recognized the Abdul Mah supposedly as
one of the Islamic terrorists that had
operated in Syria when they were there
and who terrorized them and who
eventually caused them to flee even
though now he had come back and had
joined them and was in the nation as
well in France uh they even gave his
name as silan maid and it said that they
they pointed out basically basically
that there's a lot of his kind uh
clandestine Muslim terrorists operating
in Europe and then more recently this
was confirmed by a young Frenchman Henry
Deon
selm uh who had actually intervened and
helped stop the the French playground
spree of this supposed Abdul msah
servant of Christ he also revealed in an
in a recent interview that a magistrate
had confirmed to him that the stabber
was not Christian but a member of Isis
who was pretending to be Christian of
course for those in the know Revelations
such as these that the two migrants
children in England and France where
Muslim after all are rather Superfluous
we have and rely on something called
common sense if it looks like a duck
walks like a duck quacks like a duck
it's probably a duck indeed right before
both Revelations when the media was
insisting that these two terrorists were
Christian I offered numerous reasons as
to why both were almost certainly
Muslims acting out their Jihad links to
those articles in the description the
bottom line is this Islam allows and in
some cases advocates for Muslims to
deceive non-muslims including by
pretending to be Christian this is why
I'm also convinced that all those other
terrorists who the media continue to
present as Christian such as Talib Abdul
M the Saudi who just this last Christmas
six people and injured 300 by plowing
his vehicle into them in Germany at a
Christmas Market and before him Amed
Elman who bombed a Liverpool Hospital in
2021 are and were Muslim terrorists in
sheep's clothing not only is the
deception of non-muslims and Ironclad
aspect of sharia with tea being just one
of the most notorious such doctrines but
both past and present furnish countless
examples of this phenomenon one of the
most telling comes from Spain in 14 1992
the natives of Spain the Christians
finally reconquered via the Reconquista
Granada the final Muslim Bastion in
Spain soon thereafter and because the
Denis of gonada the Muslims continue to
engage in Acts of Terror massacring
Christians plundering them here and
there whenever the circumstances allowed
all Muslims were offered two choices
convert to Christianity and by doing so
lose your jihadist hatred for Christians
and remain in Spain or stay Muslim but
quit the penin and returned to North
Africa the entire population of Granada
which at the time was hundreds of
thousands of Muslims responded by openly
embracing Christianity but remaining
crypto Muslims publicly they went to
church and baptized their children but
at home they recited the Quran preached
undying hatred for the Infidel and their
obligation to re subjugate Spain to
Islam and all of this deception was
legitimized by the fetz of leading
clerics of the day one historian Devin
Stewart in an article titled
dissimulation in Sunni Islam and morisco
tea writes the following for a marisco
which means a Muslim who openly
converted to Christianity but was a
clandestine Muslim uh for a marisco to
pass as a good Christian took more than
a simple statement to that effect it
wasn't just about saying I'm a Christian
it required a sustained performance
involving hundreds of individual
statements and actions of different
types many of which have little to do
with expressions of belief or ritual per
se dissimulation by which he means tea
was an institutionalized practice in
marisco communities Muslim communities
in Spain that involved regular patterns
of behavior passed on from one
generation to the
next despite this elaborate masquerade
Christians increasingly caught
on one Spaniard in the 17th century
wrote The Following quote with the
permission and license that their a
cursed sect meaning Islam accorded them
they could feain any religion outwardly
and without sinning as long as they kept
their hearts nevertheless devoted to
their false impostor of a prophet we saw
so many of them who died while
worshiping the cross and speaking well
of our Catholic religion yet who were
inwardly excellent Muslims in other
words generation after generation of
Muslims pretended to be and lived as
model Christians even as they had
nothing but hatred for Christianity and
Christians and all to remain and
eventually reconquer Spain for Islam now
as you can see the same thing is
continuing into the modern era for
example in 2013 an assassination plot
against a Christian pastor and his
church in Turkey was exposed 14 Muslim
suspects 14 Muslim suspects including at
least three women were arrested the
pastor in question MRA karali said that
two of them of these Muslims attended
our church for over a year and they were
like family one was even baptized in
reality these people had infiltrated our
church and collected information about
me my family and the church in order to
prepare an attack against
us so in this case Muslims converted to
Christianity devoutly attended church
and behaved like family to the pastor
and the other Christians all so they
could get close enough to kill them so
what a grand lesson here learn to trust
your instincts remember if it looks like
a duck walks like a duck and quacks like
a duck it's probably a duck employing
this duck test is especially important
nowadays when the supposed guardians of
knowledge and disseminators of news
meaning fake news have been so utterly
discredited as Liars with very obvious
pro-muslim that is to say anti-christian
agendas